bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation les guerres d'influencé
font rage elles sont même devenus la
nouvelle norme géopolitique des groupes
des états des entreprises s'en emparent
pour pousser leurs pions encore faut-il
faire le bon diagnostic
savoir déchiffrer ces stratégies d'
influence et surtout surtout se préparer
afin de riposter pour en parler je
reçois frédéric charillon professeur à
l'université clermont ferrand il signe
un livre sur le sujet intitulé guerre d'
influence les états à la conquête des
esprits un ouvrage publié chez odile
jacob
bonjour frédéric charillon première
question évidente qu'est ce que c'est
que l' influence ce n'est pas de la
propagande ce n'est pas du savent pas
aux gens non en effet c'est quelque
chose qui est qui existe depuis
longtemps auquel nous sommes habitués
par exemple dans la publicité parce
qu'après tout nous sommes sous
l'influencé de messages qui nous pousse
à changer nos comportements de
consommation par exemple bien fait une
influence c'est ça mais transposé cette
fois évidemment dans le cadre de l'étude
qui nous intéresse dans ce livre à
l'échelle politique internationale faire
changer quelqu'un de comportement c'est
à dire lui faire faire ce qu'ils
n'auraient peut-être pas fait tout seul
alors vers faire acquis à des opinions
publiques à des des leaders à des élites
à des chefs d'état étrangers sans
utiliser la contrainte parce que sinon
c'est une l'affluence ccc de la menace
et arsène et pourquoi ce n'est pas tout
à fait de la propagande parce que la
propagande a essayé de jouer plutôt sur
des foules sur des peurs sur des
réflexes irrationnels
l'influencent au contraire va essayer de
jouer sur des réflexes rationnel on va
faire comprendre à quelqu'un qu'il a
intérêt à faire à agir dans un sens qui
nous nous intéresse aussi et qu'on va y
trouver tous notre compte c'est pas non
plus tout à fait le soft power vous avez
mentionné à juste titre le soft power
c'est cette idée de puissance douce que
joseph nye un universitaire américain
avait avait mis en avant le soft power
dans son dans son idée c'est de la
séduction c'est une politique de
séduction c'est les états unis avec le
mode le rêve américain le mode de vie
américain hollywood l'image d'un pays où
on peut réussir c'est uniquement de la
séduction ça fait partie de l' influence
mais n'y a pas que ça dans une influence
on peut dans une politique d' influence
on peut aussi financer donner de
l'argent corrompt pour peut-être même
parfois mais faire en sorte que
quelqu'un change de comportement de
façon beaucoup plus intéressés et pas
uniquement parce qu'il est séduit ou
convaincu qu en tout cas l'influencent
si on veut résumer c'est parfait à
quelqu'un ce qu'il n'aurait pas fait
tout seul et lui faire changer le
comportement de manière à ce que ça nous
arrange frédéric charillon on est
d'accord pour dire que les influenceurs
ne sont pas seulement des états mais
qu'on peut trouver des groupes d
individus et des entreprises bien sûr
des groupes religieux et des entreprises
alors là dans le cadre du livre
qui vient de sortir c'est plutôt des
états parce qu'on va parler de stratégie
d'étape mais ces stratégies d'état vous
avez tout à fait raison peuvent aussi se
combiner avec d'autres vecteurs
industriels évidemment les géants du net
par exemple et parfois aussi des réseaux
religieux qui vont servir d'instrument à
ses états alors dans votre lycée
intéressant vous montrer comment un
certain nombre de pays réfléchissent de
nouveau sur une influence alors alors
qu'on pensait que les états unis on
avait un certain monopole vous vous
montrez que la russie a une influence
mellac que qu'on peut qualifier
agressive oui il ya plusieurs façons de
développer une politique d'influencé
yens il ya une tradition américaine
c'est vrai ya un vrai savoir faire
américain depuis très longtemps qui est
une sorte d' approche démocratique
libéral 1 c'est le modèle auquel nous
sommes un peu habitués nous en europe
occidentale c'est à dire on va essayer
de séduire d'attirer la versoix aussi
bien les élites par des techniques de
management par des grandes universités
où on peut réussir sa carrière et c'est
que des opinions public qu'un grand
public qui va être séduit par l'image
d'une société par ses séries télévisées
par tout ce qu'elle peut en voir en
vitrine par exemple ça c'est l'
influence typique à l'américaine je veux
dire démocratique libéral mais vous avez
un deuxième type d' influence qui est
beaucoup plus agressif vous avez raison
c'est l'affluence de régime beaucoup
plus autoritaire clio ne cherche pas
forcément à ces unions ça peut être le
cas il ya quelques années on se souvient
de l'aura du stalinisme et du maoïsme y
compris dans les sociétés occidentales
aujourd'hui c'est tout à fait ça on va
chercher plutôt qu'à convaincre de la la
bonté de son modèle on va chercher à
faire douter les opinons peu le public
des autres on va chercher alors mettre
dans l'esprit que peut-être ne vivre il
pas vraiment démocratie que peut-être
sont-ils mal traités que peut être
visitée dans un désordre et un chaos
absolu qui mériteraient qu'on y mette
bonhomme c'est plutôt quelque chose d'
agressive et de déstabilisateur et puis
il ya même un troisième modèle qui a
beaucoup de succès depuis quelques
années c'est ce qui vient plutôt des
pays du golfe ou du moyen-orient qui est
une alliance entre la foi et la croyance
religieuse et le financement de ces
réseaux religieux avec une manne
financière que nous savons être très
importante voilà civils et plusieurs
modalités d'exercice de l' influence et
la russie avaient réservé plus tôt dans
le deuxième groupe du goût la chine
voulait se situer entre 1
la séduction et l'agressivité ou pas
elle est aujourd'hui plutôt dans
l'agressivité c'est à dire qu'elles
dénoncent des modèles elle dénonce de
modèle démocratique elle estime que son
modèle est supérieur c'est-à-dire l'art
modèle très très idéologique néanmoins
elle essaye de se faire séductrice ce
qui n'est pas toujours facile parce que
la langue chinoise par exemple est bien
moins accessible que la langue anglaise
qui est répandu maintenant sur la
planète parce que aujourd'hui un déficit
d'image de la société chinoise la
pollution la vidéosurveillance etc ça
veut pas dire pour autant que la chine a
renoncé à à séduire mais pour le moment
elle est davantage dans la dénonciation
du modèle occidental démocratique et
libérale alors le le pavé que vous vous
posez avec ce livre c'est évidemment
l'absence de l'europe dans cette dans
cet échiquier vous et des mots durs vous
dites que l'europe c'est une europe
végétarienne dans un monde carnivores
donc l'europe complètement naïve ou pas
alors la formule vient d'un ancien
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères qui était effectivement une
sorte de signal
pourquoi parce que l'europe n'aime pas
ce mot d' influence ni cette technique
mes influences comme si on considérait
que c'était un peu sale comme si c'était
effectivement quelque chose qui
ressemblait à la vieille propagande et
en europe on n'aime pas ce mot de
propagande parce que ça nous rappelle
évidemment des les époque sombre et au
bout du compte effectivement les
européens aimeraient penser que l'on
peut tout à fait s'en sortir à la
régulière si je puis dire sans cessé
d'influencer les autres par leur seule
conviction de nos arguments on se
réveille un peu on se remet en train de
se réveiller un peu vous la france elle
même vient de sortir au ministère des
affaires étrangères une feuille de route
de l' influence on est en train de
prendre conscience de quelque chose de
très clair qui est que l' influence les
compétitions d' influence les guerres
d'influencé devenue la nouvelle norme
c'est devenu la règle du jeu il ya
quelques années un exemple sur les très
très intéressant il vient parle un
rapport au parlement britannique il ya
quelques mois qui évoquaient tous que la
russie allait pu faire pour déstabiliser
l'élection américaine de 2016 ou même le
référendum sur le président on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce que la conclusion
britannique soit c'est scandaleux c'est
un acte de guerre et que ça non la
conclusion ce rapport cdd peut dire mais
c'est le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est la
nouvelle règle du jeu il faut que nous
soyons habitué à soi à ça il faut qu'on
y riposte il faut qu'on y réfléchit
c'est pas la peine de passer notre vie
elle dénoncé tout le monde le fait il
faut qu'on y réfléchisse dernière
question frédéric charillon alors dans
ces cas là la diplomatie culturelle
l'influencent culturel de la france vous
la trouvez comment complètement dépassés
dont elle n'est pas dépassée elle est
importante c'est évidemment un vecteur
de rayonnement c'est un vecteur de
séduction aussi mais simplement
aujourd'hui ça ne suffit plus pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'on peut tout
à fait aimer la culture d'un pays et
même consommé sa culture ça veut pas
dire qu'on va souscrire à son modèle ça
veut pas dire qu'on va cesser combattre
pour autant merci beaucoup frédéric
charillon pour votre annonce l'entretien
de l'intelligence économique est bien
terminée mais évidemment vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur france 24
points comme au revoir
[Musique]